pour moi même macron c'est le président
de la violence un violent symbolique
mais violence réelle je vais rappeler
quand même sur les mouvements des gilets
jaunes les les chiffres qui font peur
4439 blessé il ya eu 24 éborgné 5 qui
ont vu la main arrachée plus de douze
mille cent sept personnes qui ont été
interpellées en six mois seulement avec
10000 placé en garde à vue 2000
condamnation 313 enquête pour des
soupçons de violences policières qui ont
été ouvertes et des ailes bd plus de
douze mille neuf cent cartouches ont été
tirés ça ça s'appelle de la répression
d'état il a été extrêmement violent dans
cette gestion d'une crise sociale et il
continue aujourd'hui la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans l'est dans les pôles emploi on va
mettre en place des politiques de
sécurité pour les pauvres gens qui
viennent et qu'ils ne vont pas
comprendre ce qui se passe et qui
risquerait de devenir violent donc cette
violence elle s'impose sur les français
et en plus on prépare déjà une réponse
violente à ce qui va être là mais que le
mécontentement de d'ailleurs tout à fait
légitime de ces français touchés par ces
police je vais pas défendre emmanuel
macron évidemment mais je trouve qu'ils
trouvent toujours le moyen en fait de
contourner ça aujourd'hui vous avez une
crise du gaz il va faire un chèque
énergie vadis trouvé ça tous les fruits
c'est notre argent souvenez vous quand
il est sorti de nous assure c'est notre
argent souvenez quand il est sorti de la
crise et gilet jaune action grand débat
après et en incitant toutes les
entreprises à offrir une prime de 1000
euros à chaque salarié il s'en est très
bien sorti j'ai entendu ce que vous avez
dit j'ai traversé toute la france j'ai
parlé avec tout le monde et il en est
sorti à mon avis on mais sans grand mal